Smoking cigarettes is one way in which some people reduce stress. And it may be
the case because the active ingredient in cigarettes, nicotine, actually
relaxes skelatal muscles. This is why people say smoking relaxes them. However,
we also know that nicotine activates the sympathetic nervous system. This
causes increase in heart rate and blood pressure. And, you recall, that this is
not good for extended period of time. As you recall from our lesson on
consciousness and drugs, many people use alcohol as a way to self medicate or
to reduce their stress. Alcohol is a central nervous system depressant and it
actually causes relaxation in the short run. However, long term use of alcohol
can result in a variety of negative effects, including damage to the heart,
cirrhosis of the liver, negative effects on the brain, in addition to
physiological, as well as psychological dependence.